معنا الان من رام الله مدير مكتب الجزيره
وليد العمري صباح الخير وليد قراءه طبعا
في مجمل هذه التطورات ان كان ما يتعلق
منها بالوقفات الاحتجاجيه او حتى
التصريحات على المستوى السياسي فيما يتعلق
بالحرب على
غزه الوقفات الاحتجاجيه المتواصله وتحديدا
في تل ابيب من قبل ذوي الاسرائيليين
الاسرى والمحتجزين في قطاع غزه تعكس مدى
قلقهم المتزايد لانهم يرون بان الحكومه
وتحديدا رئيسها نتنياهو لا يعيرون اهميه
او على الاقل لا يضعون قضيه اعاده ابنائهم
المحتجزين في غزه في صداره اولوياتهم لذلك
كان هذا الحراك بالامس وهو استمرار لحراك
متواصل على مدار الاسبوع منذ بدايه هذه
الحرب التي دخلت يومها الخامس اليوم
وارتفع خلال هذه المده عدد قتلى الجيش
الاسرائيلي الى
530 قتيلا بين ضابط وجندي في عمليه طوفان
الاقصى وكذلك على مدار الحرب ومن بينهم
2011 جندي وضابط قتلوا منذ بدايه الحرب
البريه في ال 26 من اكتوبر الماضي لكن قلق
هؤلاء لا يبدو انه يثير اهتماما او قلقا
لدى رئيس الوزراء بنيامين نتنياهو الذي
كان في تصريحاته امس قد عاد ليؤكد من جديد
على انه ماض في هذه الحرب حتى تحقيق
اهدافها من وجهه نظره وهي القضاء على حماس
واعاده المخطوفين حسب تعبيره وتوفير الامن
وتحقيقه الى اطول مده ممكنه للاسرائيليين
بمعنى ان يتيح لهم العوده الى مناطق غلاف
غزه هذه التصريحات التي ادلى بها نتنياهو
في مؤتمر صحفي امس سبق اجتماعين لمجلس
الحرب ولطاقم الوزاري الامني المصغر ومن
وجهه نظري ذ دوي الاسرائيليين المحتجزين
في غزه وكذلك المعارضه الاسرائيليه
البرلمانيه وقطاع متزايد في اسرائيل هي
موجهه بالاساس الى قاعدته الانتخابيه واذا
ما اخذنا بتصريحات صدرت عن زعيم المعارضه
يائير لبيد قبل قليل في حديث للاذاعه
العبريه فان نتنياهو غير قلق حسب لبيد
نتنياهو غير قلق على مصير اسرائيل هو قلق
فقط على مصالحه السياسيه الحزبيه الشخصيه
واطاله امد استمرار حكومته الحاليه لذلك
دعا لبيد الى ضروره اسقاط نتنياهو
واستبداله باقصى سرعه ممكنه تصريحات
نتنياهو ايضا جاءت موجهه الى الاداره
الامريكيه هناك معلومات تتحدث عن انها
تدفع بمنحى جديد لتسويه واسعه وهذه
التسويه تشمل عقد صفقه تبادل واسعه للاسرى
ووقف الحرب بشكل كامل وانهاء سلطه حماس او
تفكيكها وايضا الدخول في عمليه تطبيع
واسعه للعلاقات بين اسرائيل ودول عربيه
لكن نتنياهو يوجه حديثه بالاساس الى
قاعدته الانتخابيه وهو يدرك جيدا ان هذه
الحرب ستطول لكن معها ستطول ايضا حكومته
ويبدو انه قلق جدا مما تشير اليه
استطلاعات الراي الاسبوعيه مثل الاستطلاع
الذي نشرته صحيفه معاريف هذا اليوم والذي
يشير الى ان شعبيه شعبيته وشعبيه حكومته
وحزبه قد انخفضت وتواصل تراجعها وانه فيما
لو جرت الانتخابات الان فلن يجني اكثر من
16 مقعدا وان الائتلاف اليميني المتطرف
بزعامته الحالي لن يجمع اكثر من 47 مقعدا
في مقابل 67 وهي اغلبيه ساحقه لمعسكر
الدوله بقياده بيني جانس الذي تعطيه
استطلاعات الراي
39 مقعدا لكن استطلاعات الراي هي
استطلاعات للراي وهي صحيحه حتى يوم
اجرائها
لذلك فقط هي مؤشر الى اين تتجه الامور لا
اكثر هذه الامور تدفعه الى الخوف لكن
ميدانيا الامور ايضا تسير ب بمنحى يشير
الى استمرار القتال في قطاع غزه والاعلان
عن سقوط جندي واصابه ثلاثه اخرين خلال
اليومين الاخيرين مؤشر على ان المعارك
الضاريه وتحديدا في منطقه خان يونس
متواصله رغم اعلان الجيش الاسرائيلي انه
احرز تقدما وانه قضى على شبكه معامل تحت
الارض لانتاج الذخيره والصواريخ كانت
تابعه للقسام شكرا من رام الله مدير مكتب
الجزيره وليد العمري شكرا جزيلا لك